New York Fashion Week has just gotten
underway here in New York City and one
of the nation's hottest young designers
won't be taking part and that reflects
Brandon blackwood's rule-breaking
approach to the industry one that's
brought him stunning success just 31
years old he's built a multi-million
dollar company creating handbags with
outrageous resale values and dress is
now showing up on the red carpets of
award shows I had the chance to talk to
him about how far he's come and what's
behind his appeal
his Handbags and backpacks seem designed
for an already established clothing line
but that was not the case and for
designer Brandon Blackwood neither was
any big plan I would always say I never
want to be a designer because it just
seems super stressful and like a lot of
work and how you feel now
I mean I was kind of right but but I
love it
I love this Inca Gold it's really cool
the 31 year olds Kendrick trunks we do
take a lot of things for granted they
found a feverishly loyal customer base
we're gonna do a tick tock live that's
basically going to show all the
triangles all thanks to social media in
the midst of the pandemic
so you guys this is the bamboo clutch an
account he says he runs all by himself
appointment his viral pop culture
moments have struck a chord
[Music]
it's so fun and then you see you just
want to move around you and move your
hands look at that
a far cry from studying neuroscience at
Bard College on a full ride a winter
break spring break during college I
would lie to my parents and say a
science scholarship but I was really at
like nylon magazine in the fashion
closet this is our Elizabeth bag after
graduation he worked at a retail
clothing store you know retail was my
best bet to like get as close as I can
to the industry you know that's kind of
where my first fashion relationships
began his first design a backpack I
literally went on Google and the throat
handbag manufacturers and I had no plans
like starting a brand or like selling it
I just went to make something for myself
I basically lied to this Factory and I
was like yeah I'm starting a line I just
need a sample and but it sounds like a
lot of deception there are a lot of
deception it's kind of crazy so many
people would continuously stop me you
know all the others and styles I was
meeting I would show them and they were
like oh you need to sell this like this
is great
traction but no access to Capital I had
no clue how expensive it was to start a
brand I know like my first order for my
factory was me like six thousand dollars
I didn't realize like the shipping fees
the shipping fees separately like
another two thousand walking into those
meetings where you're trying to grow the
business what reaction did you get I was
like
mid-20s walking into like Barney's and
like all these stores
it was always the same reactions like
how old are you but in the summer of
2020 while the world was in lockdown and
enraged by the murder of George Floyd he
stamped his many totes with the banner
in systemic racism everything that was
going on during in 2020 I just didn't
feel like it was right to make a new
collection like it felt really like fake
I remember posting it and I didn't
expect
the reaction that got
all 500 bags he made sold out instantly
then he took the chance to slide into
the DMS of someone famous who might kick
him up to the next level almost everyone
I reach out to with like now we're gonna
stay away from this I damned um Kim
Kardashian
and I didn't expect a response and like
10 minutes later
and she's like yes send it over what do
you think it was so controversial
especially at the point of time that you
launched it I think some people
generally just did not want to fight
anymore it's not an overnight sensation
he was building up his brand for that
exact moment Naomi elizee is an editor
at Vogue for Brandon basically you can
still be exclusive while being
attainable what do you say to that I
think it just shows that there is a
market for it it is about you know being
able to be attainable to these
communities that were once excluded from
the conversations of what luxury is in
2022 he designed the red carpet look for
Cheryl Lee Ralph
who took home our first Emmy in the
dress he made just for her
I drop on the floor and just started
crying and I was like we're both
Jamaican you know it's her first win
it's like long overdue and she looks
iconic it's my first gown he's gone from
backpacks
to bags now clothing what does that say
about his brand
it shows that he is growing but also
that he is being intentional and scaling
smartly gorgeous like for a designer who
is re-engineering his take on the
fashion industry it's a strategy that
seems to be working
how do you explain having
the range of customer that you have
affordability has always been a big deal
for you I think we're allowing you
designers messed up is that
you know they'll start these Brands
they'll sell like a blouse for like
eight hundred dollars a thousand dollars
and I think that's like the first like
start to like your downfall price your
things for the people that are directly
around you that directly want to see you
in and support you and that's gonna be
the pricing that sticks
and in his pricing ranges from like
sunglasses anywhere from a hundred all
the way up to you know
other prices but but really but but
those handbags you know two three four
hundred dollars
they're way more expensive than that
um and he he caters to so many
celebrities and he just really has
caught fire I looked that jacket on you
with the feathers I don't know what that
cost but Mark should get that for you
you should get that for yourself wow and
she moves her hands around
yeah
yeah he's grown like thirty four hundred
percent it's incredible what has
happened to this gun continued success
to him